this is code red
the nation and the world are in peril
that's not hyperbole
that is a fact today's discussion of
climate and energy policy is dominated
by two overarching claims first that
fossil fuels are causing catastrophic
climate change that threatens the very
existence of the planet and second that
renewable forms of energy particularly
wind and solar can easily replace oil
gas and coal in his new book fossil
future alex epstein argues that neither
of these statements is accurate he notes
that the number of people around the
globe dying from climate-related events
has plummeted by 98 over the past
century and that wind and solar comprise
just three percent of current global
energy use an immediate shift to
renewables he argues would consign
billions to poverty or death to stave
off the impact of man-made climate
change the consequences of which have
often been exaggerated and with which
humans are equipped to deal epstein
who's the founder and president of the
center for industrial progress tells
reason about how he fought back against
a hit piece in the washington post by
using social media to tell his side of
the story and why he believes human
flourishing requires more oil coal and
natural gas not less
[Music]
alex epstein thanks for talking to
reason my pleasure
so let's uh start with an elevator pitch
for fossil future while glo why global
human flourishing requires more oil coal
and natural gas not less what's the
elevator pitch
uh the elevator pitch is that fossil
fuels if you look carefully at both the
benefits and the side effects most
people just look at side effects and
tend to exaggerate them but if you look
at both the benefits and the side
effects fossil fuels clearly have made
the world a far better place to live and
i believe the evidence is that
continuing to use them and using more of
them will make the world a much better
place to live and i would just add i
would just add one thing now in the last
six months that i think people are
realizing is that trying to rapidly
restrict fossil fuels as we've seen in
europe
really makes the world a much worse
place to live
yeah i mean for the first time in a very
long time uh kind of fuel costs have
become a kind of public policy question
right and i i particularly in europe but
also in the united states because of
inflation and you know just jack through
the roof energy prices one of the things
that you stress throughout the book
is
you know get when you when you get
outside of the wealthy west or uh the
wealthy developed world um people are
still really reliant on fossil fuels
partly because they're compact partly
because they're portable and partly
because they can be used to do all sorts
of different types of
things that
you know when people are talking about
wind and solar they're really talking
about electricity generation of a
particular kind can you just dial in a
little bit on you know you uh at times i
would almost accuse you of rhapsodizing
about you know the the fungibility of
fossil fuels uh talk a bit about that
why is that so important
so there are a bunch of different
elements let me just make sure so
there's there's the element of the
versatility is that is that the thing
that so that's the element that they can
power every type of machine that we're
used to and so within that i mean first
of all it's it's the west is
overwhelmingly fossil fueled so actually
the real distinction is that the west is
overwhelmingly fossil fueled and most of
the world wants to be fossil fueled most
of the world is very poor uh in terms of
wealth and not coincidentally in terms
of energy because energy allows you to
use machines and that's the only way to
produce
a lot of wealth um and so really we just
have a deficit in general but then when
you look at specific areas you see that
all forms of energy are not the same we
often tend to equate energy with
electricity so you hear california
generated x percent of energy from solar
and wind and it'll often be
actually electricity so around the world
electricity is only 20 of the world's
energy use now some of that can
definitely increase cost effectively but
there are many uses of fossil fuels not
for electricity and that are because
fossil fuels are by far the most
cost-effective or the only
cost-effective way to do it so why are
we using kerosene or jet fuel
to power planes it's because fossil
fuels particularly oil in this case
oil has a unique energy density it's a
very high concentration of energy in
this very stable liquid and that's why
all the planes are powered by these
fossil fuels we could talk about
hypothetical replacements called like
sustainable aviation fuels but even
there it's not electricity if you had a
battery it wouldn't work and you see a
very similar thing with cargo ships
which make the world economy run those
very not coincidentally are run on oil
now we could also talk in the future
maybe nuclear but it's instructive that
nuclear has that compactness even more
it's a little trickier to harness but it
has that so yeah this variable of
versatility is hugely ignored when we
talk about replacing fossil fuels and it
leads to things like if you look at some
of these plans they'll say oh yeah we'll
replace the planes with hydrogen planes
in the next 30 years and like we don't
have hydrogen plants right um part of uh
when
reading your book and looking at that uh
or that aspect of it it reminded me of
the uh the emphasis in michael
schellenberger's apocalypse never about
how kind of the history of energy has
been to go from more and like more kind
of diffuse
uh looser uh force
sources of energy things you know like
woods wood and twigs and and grass to
more and more dense things like nuclear
power plutonium or
coal uh
gas oil things like that
um
the you you stress throughout the book
the need to do a full cost benefit
analysis of different energy regimes
and that this tends to never happen um
because analysts and media use either
explicitly or implicitly what you call
an anti-impact framework um what is that
and how does that skew the discussion um
and what should we be on the lookout for
when we're talking about this question
of like okay how do we replace energy
with something you know that's different
than fossil fuel so just to give context
the anti-impact framework the
observations that lead to this need to
have an explanation is we tend to ignore
the benefits of fossil fuels and then
what i call catastrophize the side
effects in chapters one and two i try to
document this very thoroughly but just a
quick example is with agriculture we
tend to ignore like i give the example
of michael mann one of the world's
thought leaders on these issues and he
has a whole book on climate and energy
and he doesn't once mention the fact
that agriculture is totally dependent on
fossil fuels and fossil fuels are really
feeding eight billion people via
diesel-powered equipment and via natural
gas-derived fertilizer so my view is
this is just an intellectual crime
that's the same as if you're evaluating
a polio vaccine and you don't talk about
the fact that it stops polio and you
just talk about negative side effects
and so part of what i'm trying to get at
is why do our leaders do this
particularly the ones who know better
and my my answer is it can't they can't
be fully pro-human if they are ignoring
these huge human benefits of fossil
fuels and so one alternative explanation
i offer which i think is true for the
leaders not not so much the followers
is that they don't really think of the
benefits to human life as benefits
because their focus is eliminating human
impact on earth and if your focus is
eliminating human impact on earth you
have a hostility toward energy in
general because it leads to this high
impact industrial civilization and
you're going to have an over hostility
toward things like side effects so i'm
arguing with co2 as co2 impacts climate
but the idea that it's world ending is
not at all justifiable from a human
perspective but if your goal is to
eliminate our impact and you think the
perfect world is the one that we haven't
impacted at all it is a tragedy it is a
catastrophe because you think impact is
evil and then the other element of what
i call this anti-impact framework so
number one is human impact is evil and
our goal should be to eliminate it and
number two and this makes it seem
practical is that it's inevitably
self-destructive so it's wrong for us to
put more co2 in the atmosphere and if we
keep doing it nature is going to punish
us and you see a lot of this with the
global warming stuff it's not just this
is going to be a challenge making the
world more tropical we'll have to adapt
it's the world is going to end and so i
do consider it very much a primitive and
anti-human religion because it really
has this one commandment thou shalt not
impact nature and then if you violate
the commandment the god punishes you and
puts you in hell which is really global
warming slash climate change um i want
to get to those uh questions about
whether or not um you know our fossil
fuels are causing catastrophic climate
change um and then i want to uh talk
about you know your sense of uh can they
uh you know the belief that fossil fuels
are rapidly replaceable or can rapidly
replace uh renewable uh be replaced by
renewables um so let's let's start with
these questions of catastrophic climate
change because this is what comes up
time and time again a few years ago
after i guess it was in 2018 when the
ipcc came out with a report that was
then interpreted widely by politicians
activists in the press as saying uh you
know and perhaps most famously in
alexandria occasio cortez's uh you know
declaration which joe biden said during
the uh 2020 campaign and other people
but that we have 12 years to end you
know fossil fuels or to to get rid of
carbon being emitted into the planet
otherwise we're finished um what is the
reality is are fossil fuels causing you
know if are they causing catastrophic
climate change and if they are not what
kinds of impacts are they having but so
i guess you know just first is fossil
fuel causing catastrophic climate change
no so so far so let's i find it helpful
to start with what's the state so far
what's the present and what's the recent
past and then if we can get agreement on
that then we can trust people then we
can talk about predictions of future but
the absolute fact is that so far
fossil fuels have made the world
unnaturally safe from climate i think
that's undeniable it's never discussed
okay yeah i mean that's that's a i like
the way you say like this is just a
given this this is a bombshell right
this is going to be it's a bombshell and
it was a bombshell when i learned it and
it's even more true now and i learned it
in 2007 it's one of the things that
motivated me to talk about this because
i have been so
misled but we can quantify climate
danger and the most important thing is
how many people are dying from climate
related disasters and we can look we
have decent data 100 years back
and what we can see is that the death
rate from these things so storms flood
extreme heat extreme cold wildfire has
gone down by a rate of
98
now you would think of course it's
gotten much worse which is what i
thought uh even though i was suspicious
of the environmental movement i thought
for sure it's at least gotten worse but
it's gotten way better and when you
start to think about it it makes sense
because what we're talking about in
terms of a side effect is one degree of
warming celsius over a hundred plus
years and human beings are incredibly
adaptable and and by the way far more
people die of cold than of heat so if
you just think about it clinically and
you don't have this hatred of human
impact it's not that scary for the
overall temperatures to rise by an
average of one degree but at the same
time what of what has happened in terms
of our ability to adapt to or as i call
it master climate that has there's been
a revolution so we can now make
ourselves warm when it's freezing cold
we can make ourselves cool when it's
really hot we can do irrigation which is
maybe the most underrated thing because
that helps with drought-related death
which is historically the worst
climate-related
killer and on and on and on you can
point to all kinds of ways in which
amazing machines make us incredibly safe
from climate
and those machines are powered by fossil
fuels which provide 80 of the world's
energy and as we'll talk about in
comparison to the alternatives for very
good reasons we're not just using them
uh because of bias you know we're using
them because they are actually uh very
they're they're more cost effective than
than the alternative so the fact is that
fossil fuels have taken a naturally
dangerous climate and made it
unnaturally safe and anyone who's making
predictions about the future needs to
start there and it's very notable that
our whole establishment acts like fossil
fuels have already made climate a
disaster which to me proves that again
their goal the which means their goal is
not
there
let's put it this way
how you measure good and bad ultimately
is determined by what is your goal and i
think their goal with respect to the
world is not to advance human life or as
i call it human flourishing on earth
because if that's your goal we're far
better the climate livability is far
better but if your goal is to eliminate
human impact on earth and you just think
man-made climate change is intrinsically
immoral because it violates your
primitive anti-human religion then you
think it's a catastrophe so the only
justification for claiming catastrophe
today when we have unprecedented
livability is this anti-human
anti-impact perspective um i could see
somebody disagreeing with you and saying
but what what what is actually happening
is is that there's more intense uh
weather uh weather related events uh
weather related dislocations and things
like that and sure we can burn a lot
more gas or a lot more we can use a lot
more energy in order to kind of put a
band-aid on what's going on but
eventually i mean two things one is that
eventually we're not going to be able to
actually uh keep people from dying from
weather-related events and two uh the
climate is going to you know this this
is the hockey stick stuff that michael
mann and other people have talked about
that you know it starts out small but
you know if you if you double small
amounts consistently you know suddenly
you know we're we're boiling you know
the seas are boiling so start with that
i mean is there is there a reason to
believe that um you know we are merely
putting a band-aid on things like
dislocation uh drought other types of
things that are caused by climate change
which is caused by human activity um you
know is there a reason to to take that
seriously
so i'll give some specific scientific
facts but i want to start with just a
common sense perspective once you don't
have this perspective the human impact
is bad because my my view just so
everyone knows is that this view that
human impact is intrinsically immoral
and inevitably self-destructive is
destroying everyone's thinking about
energy and making them blind to the
obvious so you can see if you agree with
that but that is my my premise so you
think about this notice the assumption
that
rising co2 levels so we've gone from
0.03 to 0.04 percent in the of the
atmosphere of co2 the idea is we're
going to go to 0.05 percent 0.06
and notice everything is going to get
worse so that should be a red flag
immediately that we have a change in a
complex system and everything is going
to get worse right so storms are going
to get worse but also there's going to
be much more drought so we have much
more precipitation but much less
precipitation where we want it so you
could think that's okay maybe that can
happen but it should be suspicious that
everything is going to get worse the
most plausible thing that will get worse
with warming is sea levels because sea
levels you have a state of affairs where
you have built around a certain sea
level and if they were rising quickly
enough then you know that would be a
challenge at the same time you need to
recognize we have 100 million people who
already live below sea level at high
tide so we are extremely good at dealing
with sea levels and if you look at
what's happened so far it's one foot a
century which is way slower than our
ancestors and the extreme projections
are three feet of century which is very
much manageable and i think very
speculative but it's nowhere near uh
catastrophe also if you look at the
history of the earth we know that co2
levels have been 15 times higher than
they are today we know temperatures have
been much much higher than they are
today that those don't correlate so this
idea when when was that though
i mean hundreds of millions of years ago
okay i mean when humans were i mean but
was the planet would it have been
habitable for humans oh it's 100
habitable by humans yeah sorry i should
say this because it's human beings are
tropical species right it's unnatural
for us to live outside the deep tropics
we have to invent technology in order to
deal with even like the cold just a
little bit away from from the equator so
really and the other thing we kind of
know from history and from the models is
that warming tends to occur more in
colder regions so when the globe warms
it's not truly global it's more
concentrated particularly we we think
now in the more northern latitudes so
really what this means is that
rising co2 you can expect to lead slowly
to a more tropical planet that's just
what the history would tell you and you
can be concerned oh that's going to be
disruptive because the sea levels were
here and we're used to this where you
see that but the idea of catastrophe
should be absurd and the idea certainly
apocalypse and we have to remember that
fossil fuels enable us to master the
climate and enable us to do all kinds of
other things like grow food in the first
place so if you notice if you look at
the projections in the future they
almost always ignore the climate mastery
and other benefits of fossil fuels to
the point where they'll say like michael
mann they're going to make agriculture
worse but he's not concerned about what
happens if you rapidly eliminate fossil
fuels that are currently feeding eight
billion people and if you want to know
the consequences of that look at now
we're talking about starvation we have
fuel shortages we have fertilizer
shortages skyrocketing prices this is
affecting the poor world the most and
this is because we've been engaged in
this fossil fuel benefit denial that i'm
pointing out repeatedly in fossil fuels
and elsewhere and there's no reason to
believe that um you know
that climate change or you know rising
temperatures or uh extreme
concentrations of greenhouse gases will
reach a tipping point that's a bad
metaphor but we'll reach a point where
they just start to
really get out of hand in a really big
way i mean you know we're coming out of
a covet pandemic where uh it took people
a while to understand the fact that
diseases can um you know that they can
multiply geometrically as opposed to you
know just in in terms of simple addition
yes it's the opposite this is the
opposite of how greenhouse gases and
many other phenomena in nature work and
this is what i'm saying here and most of
what i say is not sort of challenging
the mainstream science on this what i'm
doing is i'm interpreting it without
this bias against human impact in the
full context of the benefits that come
along with
these uh these impacts so as i talk
about in chapter nine of the book you
know if the trajectory of the greenhouse
effect of co2 was was like what it is at
the early stages of a pandemic that
would be really scary right because it's
it's you know it looks like it's you can
call it a super linear function it
doesn't just go like this it goes like
this and you don't want that happening
with the temperature but as i indicated
we've had earth with 15 times more co2
and that the thing didn't burn up so we
know it's not this kind of effect and if
you look at the science it's regarded
universally as a logarithmic effect
which means a decelerating effect so it
looks like
this so you can think of it as every new
molecule of co2
warms but it warms less than the last so
it has it's you get diminishing returns
heat-wise on every new molecule of co2
all of the talk of tipping points and
that is a term that is used by certain
at least activists
what that involves is it involves some
change
it's not the greenhouse effect itself it
involves some kind of feedback so for
example they'll say well it's going to
lead to permafrost uh being released in
the arctic and that's going to lead to
this but when you look into all of these
they're either extremely speculative or
they tend to get misinterpreted so one
study i looked at with the permafrost is
they said it'll in effect be over the
next 300 years the equivalent of 10 more
years of our emissions so that's
something but it's not the end of the
world and why would we expect it to be
the end of the world given that again
we've had far more co2 the planet didn't
end it was a more tropical place so you
need to think about this in a measured
way and not this were evil god is going
to punish us
where where do you think that's coming
from i mean you you know when you when
you talk about that in your writing and
just now
um there did seem to be uh
in the in the modern environmentalist
movement and perhaps starting in the 70s
and certainly in the 80s there were a
number of people or groups that started
to advance this idea
that you know humans uh humans are
arrogant and hubristic and uh you know
if they center everything about their
outcome they're destroying you know
mother earth gaia or whatever um and i
can remember reading and i know reason
uh wrote some stories critiquing this
sort of thing where environmentalists
would talk about humans almost as a
virus or a cancer on the planet like we
were the disease uh ultimately and
because of that we were a parasite that
was taking over the planet that sort of
rhetoric has definitely vanished at
least explicitly but could you talk a
little bit about the deeper roots of it
yeah i think so i i i know very few
people who say uh you know who are like
uh you know the real problem is we need
many fewer humans uh even you know
sure that's yeah you know it's like the
zero population growth uh the idea that
there are too many people and possibly
too many people moving to the u.s you
know that's still around but it's it
it's definitely not foregrounded or the
idea that humans are the disease um but
where did that where did that original
you know kind of uh philosophical or uh
rhetorical thrust come from so it's
there's at least two two big origins so
one is in primitive religions you have
this idea that i call the delicate
nurturer assumption which is that nature
exists in this delicate balance that
nurtures us so i think of as it's stable
it's sufficient and safe but our impact
ruins it and you can understand why
primitive religions would have this view
because they kind of they don't
understand cause and effect in science
and so they assume some consciousness is
controlling everything and they want
control so they're like oh if i dance
there will be rain so you kind of get
that but it doesn't have the hostility
toward so it has this view that our
impact can be dangerous and we need to
manage it but it doesn't have the
hostility now still you definitely see
in people like rousseau so you kind of
see people who are the benefits of
industrialization or at least more
prosperity like they have this they have
this myth of a better time when we're in
harmony with you
in their in their defense also perhaps
uh in the thick of the industrial
revolution where there was a you know
within a few decades radical changes in
very local climates you know soot uh
things like that yeah they could be like
wow we're really [ __ ] up the planet
yeah and i think it's more of the view i
mean there are a lot of people like oh i
have a country home and i like why does
it why can't everything be like this and
they don't really appreciate it because
a lot of people are choosing them to
live in the cities and they don't maybe
have the same attitude that we would
have because they they know what it's
like there's no question and i i'm sorry
to step on your toes here but it you
know that um you know
i think this is true of every ideology
but environmentalism perhaps more than
others people uh of means generally come
up with a vision that they think is
beautiful and should be shared by
everyone and then when they find out
yeah you know like i actually like
living in a basement apartment in a city
where there's a lot of garbage on the
street relatively speaking to your
country house and that you know they
they feel a need to control that rather
than to kind of abide it yeah i mean in
general these coercive movements they
don't like what people actually want
they have their view of oh this is what
the people want this and it's what my
vision is and it involves me being very
important and me having control and why
don't the people want this this is the
whole history but i would say
if we're talking about so if this is
actually relevant i'm talking about
collectivists and status in general but
i think that this is a point i got from
iran i definitely agree with that is
that this whole anti-human environmental
movement really emerges in the late 60s
and early 70s but it's it's that strain
was there but it got promoted very
widely by the political left because
they found that attacking capitalism on
environmental grounds was very very
effective i think this in part was a
failure of the pro-capitalism side to
own the issue of environment that's one
thing i try to do in fossil future and
elsewhere say hey if you want a livable
human environment you need freedom you
need fossil fuels the natural
environment is not a livable human
environment including like clean water
you don't have abundant clean water or
natural environment nor abundant nor
clean air because you need to burn
something to keep warm in most places
and that's going to be water animal dog
unless you have modern uh modern fuel so
it there is really a a concerted effort
to to put over what i consider this
anti-human environmental philosophy and
all of the concrete scares that go along
with it really starting in the the 80s
the 70s 80s and it penetrates the
educational system which means it
penetrates the media and i think that's
why you have the whole world obsessed
with how do we eliminate the impact of
our co2 emissions and the expectation
that the world is going to end in a
world where as hopefully we'll talk
about billions of people are lacking
energy billions of people are poor where
it's pretty obvious that from that
perspective we need a lot more fossil
fuel and yet we're trying to figure out
how do we get rid of fossil fuel even
though that's 80 of the energy in the
world that does have energy and most of
the world doesn't have energy uh before
we move off this point uh let me ask you
a question about you know in in the late
60s and early 70s when the kind of
modern green movement the modern
environmental movement was uh created
earth day comes around and things like
that um i'm old enough to actually
remember the crime the famous crying
indian uh uh public service ad
um you know and there was garbage
everywhere and and of course you know
garbage on the street is not the same
thing as you know uh co2 or you know the
air air pollution being a problem but
air pollution was a problem uh you know
and
when people would fly into places like
los angeles or houston you would kind of
descend through
a haze of all sorts of things um all of
those places now have much much better
air quality even though we produce far
far more energy we have you know about a
third or 50 percent more people uh you
know in these places you know there is
so much more activity going on
everything is better
what was the role though of government
regulation in helping to clean those
things up because i think as you know as
good libertarians we are always slow to
acknowledge any possible good coming out
of you know a kind of top-down coercive
structure
but with things like the clean air act
and the clean water act and various
kinds of environmental um
rules and laws
did they have a positive effect on you
know day-to-day living conditions
and if so why does it seem that
capitalists you know are always the
people are saying no any regulation will
will absolutely destroy all aspects of
prosperity so we can't do that and then
later they come back and say hey look
everything's getting better but can you
talk a little bit about that you know
it's a kind of weird two step on our
side of the equation i think
yeah well so let me talk about how i
think our side of the equation should
view it versus how it's viewed i think
um you know one of the criticisms of
libertarianism which has a broad kind of
conception but about like what's the
objectivist criticism and part of it is
a hostility toward government as such
versus a hostility toward government
violating its proper functions and part
of this view which i share is that
there's a government is a crucial ally
in liberty
and
but it needs to be delimited and that's
hard to do and unfortunately ours has
gone in the wrong direction but we
definitely need governments and so part
of that is the government is supposed to
protect against rights violations and
you can absolutely consider certain
kinds of pollution rights violations the
most obvious is a kind of tort situation
where you're just dumping stuff on your
neighbor's uh property but it's also
totally valid at a given state of
technology to say hey to for human
beings to survive and flourish we don't
need to emit this much soot in the
atmosphere and so we're gonna say
you're not allowed to do that now you
can't say that at every stage so it's
very contextual in history so for
example imagine a pro-freedom government
in the time of the caveman we can't say
don't use fire because it has harmful
smoke even though the smoke is harmful
in and of itself because it's a
byproduct of something that is crucial
to
living but over time what happens is you
get cleaner and cleaner ways to generate
energy that are quite
low cost sometimes even superior so in
some cases say natural gas not all but
is superior to coal in that case it's
totally legitimate to say hey we're
going to have standards that say you
can't emit so much because it's it's
unnecessary and it is harmful but i
think it's very important to think from
a libertarian or pro-freedom perspective
think in terms of rights and rights
violations and how does the government
define different kinds of rights versus
the overarching term of regulation which
just means anything the government feels
like doing and so we don't want to we
don't want to call we don't want to we
don't want to give a positive view of
rights protection as regulation because
then that justifies all of this
preemptive or preventative stuff where
the government is treating us as guilty
until proven in us and that's really
what the essence of regulations or
controls are today is that they they are
treating us as guilty until proven
innocent the same thing by the way just
as a quick comment with coven this is
one of the issues that i had with how it
was discussed like i thought it was
legitimate i still do is for the
government to say if you are a
demonstrable danger to your neighbors we
can say you can quarantine that's
different from saying you might be a
danger and therefore we can force you to
quarantine with no evidence and and one
thing i said which i really think proved
to be true is like innocent until proven
guilty is a very underrated principle in
american law and you get so far just by
following that principle so with the air
pollution it's the clean air act is kind
of a mess in that there's some good
elements and some bad elements and it's
being used in really bad ways today
including with co2 which it wasn't
intended to do um but in general what
you see is a progression where people
become wealthier they want cleaner air
they develop better technology and they
properly pass laws and so that's that's
something that pro-freedom people should
totally get behind versus just resisting
at every stage because there was clearly
a point where that level of pollution
was not necessary
given and it was reasonably preventable
and so to resist that then it it
concedes to the other side that you
don't care about a good environment and
that's that's a terrible thing to
concede
um
kind of related to that um i would say
people broadly speaking let's call it
the the pro-market side uh tended to be
pretty slow to agree with the idea that
uh you know human activity was causing
was having an effect on the climate um
and you know as a result uh you know in
in a way i think you could say those
people still uh perform a meaningful
function by kind of dragging down you
know a race to some kind of unproven
goal that you know is is kind of like a
french revolution style thing like uh we
need to radically change everything
overnight otherwise you know something
disastrous is going to happen but it
does lead to a credibility question
doesn't it if
people who are broadly speaking you know
pro-market um are constantly saying no
you know uh global warming is is a
communist plot global warming is is bs
it's a means of social control simply
there's no science there's no science
and then well there is science and i
believe in the science but it's not as
bad as they say i mean can you
um you know what what is a better way
again on on a kind of pro market on a on
a kind of pro human pro-market side what
is a better way to actually kind of
engage with
ongoing inquiry and ongoing you know new
information that actually changes the
way we should be talking about things
i think it's it's really important issue
so i think the way from both sides the
fossil fuel issue has been framed and
and i would give myself credit for
helping reframe and a handful of other
people like shellenberger and lomborg
and
the way it has been framed i talked
about this in chapter 11 of the book
which is about persuading people on
these issues
is it's been framed as either you
believe that fossil fuels impact climate
and therefore they're bad
or
you to believe they don't impact climate
and therefore they're okay and i use
okay very deliberately because i think
before i came along there was very
little focus on the benefits of fossil
fuels and the implicit idea behind both
sides of this alternative is that impact
is bad and it should make us take
drastic action because i think if you
just step back and look at co2 look
we're putting co2 it's a warming gas and
a fertilizing gas we're putting more of
it in the atmosphere we should expect
impacts we should expect impacts from a
lot of things that we do i mean you hear
about butterfly effect i don't know the
science of that but in general we are
radically transforming the earth to be a
much more livable place we're trying to
do that and they're absolutely going to
be side effects and we absolutely need
to study
those side effects and take them
seriously and we cannot be on the
premise that we're only allowed to do
things if they have no impact i think
this is another failure of some
libertarian thinkers is there's this
atomistic view of liberty which is the
idea that you're allowed to take action
as long as it has no effect on anyone
and i don't think that's at all the
founders conception of liberty it's
because you're going to have effects on
a lot of people in a lot of different
ways and so part of what the law is
trying to do is how to define your
freedom of action so that you can't
affect them in a way that fundamentally
impedes their freedom of action and yeah
talk about more sometimes but it's it's
it's not like
no
it's not like you say oh you have a
right to do whatever you want but if one
molecule of of a negative thing gets in
everyone else's air then you're a slave
which i think people accept that view
and you need to reject that you need to
embrace the fact that our actions are
going to have impacts and we need to
define liberty recognizing that i you
know i i really appreciate in the book
uh in particular i mean it's obviously
it's about energy policy it's about
climate change it's about a lot of
things but it is also a book about
persuasion and i was thinking you know i
can remember a time when you were fond
of kind of going to environmental uh
debate or uh
uh you know events and wearing like you
know i love fossil fuels
types of t-shirts and things like that
which has a place right because it's
provocative and everything but would you
say you as you as you've developed as a
thinker and as a writer that you are
focusing more on a kind of on persuasion
rather than kind of expression of core
beliefs
yeah although i think i've been always
interested in that kind of thing so i've
had controversial i've had very
controversial views since i was a
teenager i mean even before i got a dime
ran when i was 18 but even before then i
was in a liberal environment and i sort
of got into conservative and libertarian
ideas and the one one thing that i had i
don't know why i had it but i considered
a gift is i really wanted other people
to agree with me i didn't get off too
much on being different i just really
thought these ideas are right and i
wanted other people to agree and so
every time i had a conversation and it
didn't go well i would reflect on it i
really want it to go well versus i think
many people who have contrarian ideas
they like being different and so that
leads to just these expressions of oh i
have this very different view and you
guys are wrong and yeah
become an edge lord right where it's
like the more people disagree with you
the more correct you feel you are and
then you want to take it even further i
mean that that is not you but so a lot
of people are like that yeah and so so
my own i mean i think i've improved in
that way um for sure so but i love
fossil fueling is even that's designed
to be provocative to get attention but
it's not an argument by itself but but
just to give you a sense of fossil
future and this was this was something
where i already had a best-selling book
on fossil fuels i had a name
but i had this conviction that i could
do much better in terms of persuading
people and empowering allies so i spent
three years on a risky thing which is
writing a new book on a on the same
topic
and it was real the whole thing was
we're at this key moment where i think
the whole world is going in the wrong
direction i think now we're getting
evidence of that and it's like what can
i do to try to persuade people and it's
just every sentence is trying to
persuade somebody who expects to
disagree and that's like from beginning
to end when i write a book it's i'm
trying to take somebody who expects to
disagree and persuade them and then part
of that is i'm trying to take my allies
and get get them much better at
persuading people who expect to disagree
so i'm i'm obsessed with intellectual
persuasion and i'm not at all obsessed
with being different i i would i would
love it to get out of this issue and for
everyone to agree i'll i'm very happy
doing other things
um so i i want to switch now to
questions about whether or not fossil
fuels are in fact easily replaceable or
immediately replaceable by renewables
but just to cap this then yeah because
the the first part of the argument is or
you know of reaching people is to you
know really kind of convince or make a
case that climate change is not
imminently catastrophic um what's the
you know what's the one or two sentence
version of that argument well i would
just say that the i think there are
three issues so one is i don't think
with with the overall so there's the
issue of climate catastrophe fossil
fuels are climate causing climate
catastrophe that they're rapidly
replaceable by renewables but i see the
third thing and i focus a lot on this in
fossil fuels just recognizing how
beneficial fossil fuels are for the
world as a whole and i think that is
really crucial for people to get and
once you get that you see these other
you become afraid of fossil fuels not
becoming replaceable
and and then we'll talk about the
climate the key things with climate are
you first have to recognize that climate
that fossil fuels give us an enormous
positive ability to master climate that
have made that has made us rapidly safe
radically rather safer from climate like
you have to recognize we're safer than
ever from climate and fossil fuel
machines are a root cause of that and
then also that
they have this warming effect also
fertilizing effect from rising co2 that
is a diminishing effect that we can
expect to continue warming but that
cannot cause an amount of warming or
other climate change that could be
catastrophic let alone an apocalyptic so
we should expect a more empowered world
and a more tropical world and will
overall be even safer from climate and
will be far better off and everything
else
all right uh okay so now let's talk
about the and in that case you don't
really need there's really a suspicion
of why do you need to replace them if
they're that good and then and then it
it casts suspicion on why are we so
intent on getting rid of them
immediately like even if you think i'd
rather not have this much co2 this idea
of let's have this crash program to get
rid of this immediately in a world this
is really important in a world where
most people have very little energy we
always have to remember this i stress
this a lot
the most people don't have energy so
when we're talking about replacing
fossil fuels it's not just for us it's
for billions of people who lack energy
um and that seems to be happening
somewhat or or rather we're using and i
guess this is an old uh conundrum and a
tricky one everything is getting more
fuel efficient everything is getting
more efficient but also that doesn't
lead to less energy being used does it
yeah so there's a bunch of i talked
about this i think in chapter five
there's a lot of elements of the
fallacies here but the most obvious
thing
is just that so people lack energy on
such a large scale that even us becoming
more fuel efficient even and if that
didn't lead to other what are called
rebound effects you still need vastly
more energy levels that's the one i
focus on but there are other things as
well including we have new ways of using
energy the whole crypto bitcoin space is
an example of that but the modern
internet is an example of that they're
building new server farms like crazy
and computers have an effectively
unlimited need for energy because we can
always find new things to figure out
particularly in medical research so
and then and then there's just
people who are at a certain level now
want to be wealthier and that involves
more energy so you can think of like al
gore and john kerry's lifestyle other
people would like some fraction of that
so they're all these energy efficiency
is great but it's part of people
improving their lives and pursuing
economic efficiency and part of that is
yet people they'll use energy more
efficiently and they'll also want to use
more energy and that's a very healthy
motivation most people saying they
shouldn't do that are using way more
energy
than the people they're criticizing
although that leads to a discussion of
renewables or sustainable energy sources
of saying you know that are that are
less polluting or non-polluting right so
that's kind of a way
of having your cake and eating it too
although i realize a lot of
environmentalists really seem to just
want less energy to be used that's kind
of a separate issue right they're kind
of puritanical or ascetics and they just
they kind of envision a world where less
stuff is going on because that comports
with their vision of you know the one in
true uh heaven one and only heaven but
then when we get to renewables this is
part of the case for renewables right
that we could actually have you know
massive unlimited energy and it's not
going to do any harm to anybody right um
but before we get there let's talk about
the state of renewables i hear this uh
you know all the time i have two uh two
sons in their 20s they have gotten a
steady diet of this their entire life
that
solar and wind in particular are cheaper
now are you know they are just as viable
as you know existing sources of energy
and all we need is a kind of uh you know
triumph of the will to switch over to
these things
what is wrong about that
well what's funny is that you don't
usually need a triumph of will if things
are really super you don't need a
triumph of political will right it just
it just happens automatically so again i
want to point to things that kind of
anyone can observe that cast suspicious
suspicion on this
so one is that the concentration of
solar and wind is very correlated to the
amount of government preference given to
them so they there are mandates where
you say explicitly you need this much
solar wind there are subsidies where you
give them you give people extra money
for using them and for producing them
and then also the most underrated thing
is we have grids that pay the same
amount for unreliable uncontrollable
electricity as for reliable controllable
electricity which is crazy you would
never do that in any other context so
why is it that
they need so much favoritism if they're
superior and then the other thing that's
just common sense is what does it mean
to say something is cheaper when it's
not reliable it's clearly just think
about common sense like electricity from
the sun electricity from the wind
absent some amazing storage system which
we don't have
that is not the same at all as
electricity that you can control the
amount that you have when you want it so
the miracle of electricity is we can
have unpredictable or unknown demand
let's say uncontrollable demand and
highly controllable supply that's the
miracle of the grid right is whatever we
do in terms of demand we they can
control the supply so that we have our
electricity that is amazing but
controllability is the essence of it and
so what what does it mean to say that
this uncontrollable thing is cheaper
than this controllable thing and so my
the basic fallacy that's going on is
people are not looking at the total
process of producing reliable
electricity and i emphasize reliable
electricity what they're doing is
they're saying hey these solar panels on
their own are cheaper than the coal or
something you know the coal equivalent
but they're not looking at the full cost
because when you look at the full cost
you need to look at the solar panels the
infrastruct all the new infrastructure
but most importantly the near 100 backup
that's needed because solar and wind can
go to near zero at any time and so in
fossil future one i argue once you look
at that these things are costly and they
also don't scale so even if they were
cheaper for five percent of the
electricity or 10 which they're not in
most cases that doesn't mean they can
provide 100
and as we talked about before
electricity is not all energy so a lot
of energy isn't produced it isn't isn't
generated using electricity uh isn't
provided using electricity so there's
all these all these signs that there is
something really really off but the main
the main fallacy is what i call partial
cost accounting you're not looking at
the full cost of producing reliable
electricity you're just looking at a
partial cost and that's that should be
viewed as very manipulative and suspect
in addition to the fact that they want
to use force as against as against
having some kind of real market what
about uh you know then there's the
argument said okay yeah you know uh
solar you know sometimes the wind isn't
blowing uh you know the sun sets at
various points but we are about to build
uh either batteries or
kind of transmission wires where we're
able to get this stuff uh you know to to
hold it in a balance until it's actually
necessary or send it out to where it is
necessary even if it's not in the
immediate place that it's being produced
is is that viable or is that actually
happening so
i think it's important with all these
things
that all of these things i'll talk about
batteries in the other one in a second
but these things definitely have not
been done at all and we're talking about
forcing the whole world to rely on them
in 27 and a half years so this this i
want this to be very scary to people
this is really a potential apocalypse
because the whole world depends on
energy we're talking about rapidly
eliminating fossil fuels
with these schemes that have definitely
never been done nobody can argue that
these schemes have actually happened
where we have a whole grid that solar
and wind and either you have this
massive battery or interconnected it's
also true that these schemes all involve
unprecedented amounts of mining and
unprecedented amounts of infrastructure
development that's unquestionable they
require far more than has ever occurred
on a crash timetable that has never
occurred
and then and both of those things by the
way doing something totally
unprecedented and do and doing a crash
program of unprecedented development
both of those we know add massive
amounts of cost to things so if you if
people are telling you it's cheap i say
that's basically proof that they're a
fraud and then the third thing that
proves it's a total fraud is all of this
is in an anti-development environment
that the green movement supports so
think about how hard it is to build a
lithium mine in the u.s or do any kind
of mining or lay transmission lines we
have a whole green movement that says
it's bad to impact nature and they're
going to allow us to engage in a totally
unprecedented amount of mining and
infrastructure building so it's all this
should just all be viewed as absurd this
is like the most absurd central plan
ever that this is going to happen you
can do this thing that's never been done
unprecedented amounts of development and
an anti-development environment so i
think common sense just says this stuff
is all absurd and it's really motivated
by
a hostility toward energy a hostility
toward human impact and not caring about
if it's replaced plus we're having an
energy crisis right now where clearly
people overestimated the ability of
fossil fuels to be replaced because we
have shortages of them and it's not
because of lack of physical supply it's
not because of lack of technical
knowledge it's because for various
reasons both government force and some
private actors we have we have uh
prevented fossil fuel investment
prevented production prevented
transportation so i go into the battery
stuff i mean the batteries are like if
you run the numbers backing up the world
for three days it's 400 trillion dollars
okay so this is just this is just
an um just a crazy thing the
transmission lines thing again there's
nothing resembling this you can have
very large droughts of sunlight and wind
in a lot of different regions so this is
just all crackpot stuff
and my argument is it's it's it's it's
created by people who don't really care
about energy because if you care about
energy your whole focus would be how do
we get more energy from more people as
quickly as possible not how do we
eliminate our number one currently
irreplaceable source of energy in the
next 27 and a half years and somehow
it'll work i don't think they care about
the somehow i think it's all just hand
waving could you uh talk a bit right now
in the united states obviously we have
you know uh historically high or
certainly for uh you know for the past
couple of decades high gas prices high
energy prices in general
what are the policies uh that whether it
was under donald trump or joe biden or
whoever what are the policies that have
led to this and are there any benefits
to having restricted the production of
uh you know coal oil and gas
i don't think there are any benefits and
i think the cause is
is the restriction and so what we had
was and you know we have we've had this
anti-fossil fuel movement that said you
know don't invest in fossil fuels
don't produce them
don't build the transportation
infrastructure and then we had and so
that was going on and then we had a
pandemic where demand for fossil fuel
went down and so a lot of people
celebrated and said oh well we don't
need fossil fuel anymore i mean you had
people predicting you know oil prices
will never go above 30 again and all of
these different things and so that
empowered even more the anti-fossil fuel
political movement as as uh also as in
addition to you know what's called the
esg movement which is a quasi-private
quasi-governmental thing that's put
environmental social governance movement
which in particular is environmental
here which is saying fossil fuels are
environmentally bad so you should
eliminate them so you have drastic
declines of investment in fossil fuel
and everyone's saying this is great
solar and wind are going to replace them
but what happened is there wasn't really
the ability to replace fossil fuels of
solar and wind so what happened is many
nations around the world restricted
their own ability to supply them but
they still needed them so demand
increased relative to supply
particularly post pandemic and we just
didn't have the ability to recover even
though we have the physical resource and
we have the technical knowledge so it's
just a very simple issue of supply and
demand we artificially restricted supply
on the false promise that it would be
replaced by solar and wind supply and
it's
it hasn't happened and it's
it's really tragic i mean just it's not
reported enough just in terms of what do
fertilizer
uh prices skyrocketing mean what what
are all these shortages happening around
the world what does it mean we're
talking about starvation there's we
should never be talking about starvation
globally because we're so good at
producing food
but we've inhibited our ability and i
hope that the fact that i hope this is
an educational moment i think it's an
educational moment for inflation but i
hope i also hope it's an educational
moment for energy where people realize
this is really important and we haven't
been thinking about it the right way and
we need to think about it in a new way
including looking at the actual benefits
and the unique benefits of fossil fuels
discuss the esg movement a little bit
how where where did it come from and how
widespread is it because this is
something that over the past
uh year or two really has kind of burst
into the public consciousness and it
seems to be everywhere where did it come
from what are its goals and what are you
most worried about from it
so this is a movement i'm very very
worried about um it's there's actually
some good counter signs at the moment
but
so it's it's more broadly part of what's
called the stakeholder capitalism
movement and so it's it that movement is
basically based on a caricature of
profit which is to say that to pursue
profit is to be short range and kind of
narrowly focused like you don't care
about the long term you just want money
now and you don't care about anyone you
deal with you don't care about people
you're just totally indifferent you want
to screw them and you want to screw up
your environment and there's a total
character that's not how profit works
how profit works because you're trying
to create value in the long term and you
are thinking about long-term long-term
considerations and you have you're very
aware of different wide-ranging
considerations that affect you such as
your communities obviously you're um
obviously the people who work at your
company uh you know obviously like the
physical environment you live in and
what the stakeholder thing says is we
need to throw out because profit is so
bad it just makes you short-range and
indifferent we need instead you need to
pursue the stakeholders that should be
your focus but stakeholders is like the
common good it's this totally
meaningless term and so what it means is
in practice you just pursue whatever
goal whoever is defining stakeholder at
the moment does and so esg is part of
this it in particular came from the un
but basically they're saying is to be a
good company you have to pursue certain
environmental social and governments nor
and governance norms that we have
determined to be
quote unquote in the interest of
stakeholders and it's like really the un
is going to come up with some what do
they know about business right so it's
these people who know nothing about
business imposing all these norms i
would argue in the social realm they
have a lot of anti-individualist
actually racist ideas
but in the environmental realm certainly
there's a lot of hostility toward
nuclear which is very revealing and
interesting and there's huge hostility
toward fossil fuels saying to be
environmentally responsible is to get
rid of fossil fuels rapidly and so all
these companies have been pressured into
don't invest in fossil fuels sometimes
even don't insure fossil fuel like power
plants which is really scary
and and it's it's overtaken corporate
america some with support of government
some i think a lot of status seeking
people maybe the biggest mechanism is a
lot of us are invested in index funds
for good reasons you know funds that
reflect the market and you know we
invest in blackrock vanguard and state
street so they control it a staggering
percentage of the stocks of of big
companies and because of laws and
because of other things they then get to
vote those and they are voting them very
much in favor of rapid elimination of
fossil fuels so what they're able to do
is impose via corporate pressure things
that voters will not vote for so they
have become like real kind of overlords
based on this and it is it is very scary
fortunately there is some pushback but
man it i i've been consulting with
people in the energy industry for a
while and a few years ago everyone went
from nobody would talk about esg to
everyone would talk about esg and was
just scrambling to have an esg policy a
sustainability policy so
i find it really scary that these status
like i'm i'm scared of what voters can
do but i'm much more scared of what
status seeking corporate people who
don't need money but want to be seen as
do-gooders
that scares me the most well and it's an
interesting challenge to a kind of uh
limited uh broadly libertarian view that
you know the state is the thing you have
to worry about but when you know when
you have the biggest mutual fund
companies in the world or big corporate
holding companies saying you know what
because of a few people in that saying i
believe in this and i'm going to push
that through all of our holdings that's
a uh
that's a lot to deal with right yeah
there are there are there is a big issue
but there are a lot of government
controls that are that are fostering
this in different kinds of ways
administration doing this but yeah it is
the kind of thing certainly where there
is a it's a the fact that you believe in
freedom does not mean that everything
that happens in the society will just
automatically be good and so there is a
responsibility to out-compete people and
to boycott people and and i was talking
there's a guy you might have heard of
him named vivek ramaswamy he wrote the
book called woke inc and i just
interviewed him for my podcast power
hour which should come out um i mean
this is the week of the 18th it should
come out later this week
and he has just announced they're doing
a counter kind of esg thing they haven't
announced exactly what they're doing but
they're really trying to take on these
companies and do some of what these
companies do
but instead of encouraging them to
follow these un norms they're saying no
pursue excellence be excellent at
whatever you're doing so to me that's an
exciting kind of pro-freedom approach to
countering this stuff let's talk about
nuclear power which uh unlike uh wind
and solar has more of uh you know it has
a track record in the history and you
can point to at the very least countries
like france where they uh get a majority
of their electricity if not their energy
from nuclear power
with with an absolutely incredible
safety record uh people like michael
schellenberger believe that nuclear is
the future for a wide variety of reasons
um it is fascinating now to see people
who are
climate alarmists who are saying we need
to get off of fossil fuels we need to
get rid of carbon you know by 2050 or
you know by 2030 by 2050 by whatever
otherwise we're cooked
still
resisting nuclear um how does nuclear
power fit into your fossil future um
because you know in the book i mean you
have good things to say about it but
it's also you know it's it's not fossil
fuel um so you know what what what is
your attitude towards nuclear and what
kind of role should nuclear power play
in a in a in an energy abundant future
yeah so it's all about an energy
abundant future i don't have a fetish
for fossil fuels i know people will
think that but it's like no i don't have
that uh and i was thinking that you must
have had a pet dinosaur growing up or
something no no no no i didn't my whole
background is you know liberal
environment hostility toward fossil
fuels afraid of climate change that kind
of thing
um
so nuclear is is amazing you know it's
the you think about fossil fuels they
part of what makes them remarkable is
there i talk about this in chapter five
they're naturally stored naturally
concentrated naturally abundant source
of energy and you don't really have that
in any alternative yeah so so where does
where does nuclear energy fit into your
energy abundant future yeah so the
number one thing is i like that you say
energy abundant future because i don't
have some sort of fetish toward fossil
fuels like if you look at my focus it's
all about global human flourishing how
do you have a world where everyone has
an opportunity to flourish and then
recognizing that you need energy that's
low-cost reliable versatile and scalable
and it's all about fossil fuels are
amazing because they're the one thing
that does that now and for the
foreseeable future i argue that they're
the only thing that can do
that and so
the reason and you might think well
nuclear nuclear is amazing because that
is like fossil fuels it's concentrated
so it can store a lot of energy in a
small space and in fact it's even more
it's even more concentrated than
phosphorus plus it's stored energy it's
incredibly abundant it's amazing um and
i think that if we had a different world
without a green movement 40 50 years ago
we could have a dominantly
nuclear-powered world i'm not sure about
that but it's possible but unfortunately
what happened is nuclear in the 70s
showed immense promise it was way
cheaper than it is now and there was
every reason to believe it could be made
cheaper so let's say it took four years
to make a nuclear plant from beginning
to end
given technology and improvements it
should have gone down to two years but
what happened instead is it went up to
16 years and it can be stopped at any
time a lot of these nuclear pens can
just be stopped in their tracks and
billions of dollars go up in smoke so
what i argue has happened is nuclear has
been essentially criminalized by the
free world at least much of the free
world including the parts of the world
namely the us were the most innovation
you can expect to occur okay france is
good but they have kind of a
government-controlled thing like what
you really need is a free market and
nuclear and i think that should be
possible and i argue for that and i
fight for that i think harder than
anyone but given the state of where
nuclear is today which is it's declining
in a lot of the world it's criminalized
there is no way shape or form it is
going to be a replacement for fossil
fuels for electricity but let alone all
the other forms of energy on this crash
timetable so i do think that we should
be liberating nuclear as quickly as
possible and the connection is a fossil
future but the the one of the great
outcomes of a fossil future is it will
it will turn into a nuclear future
but if you try to get rid of a fossil
future you will not have a nuclear
future you will just have a bad future
and there's uh things like hydroelectric
power which is another substantial
source of of energy around the world
what are the what are the natural
limitations for hydroelectric um
yeah so it's worth saying nuclear
doesn't have these limitations i
mentioned just in passing it's abundant
i hope i did it's uh yeah so essentially
there's enough of the raw material for
it in various forms where you can use it
you know for centuries really are
arguably eons to come
uh some people argue billions of years
but that doesn't matter right because
technology evolves you don't need
something that lasts millions of years
you just need something that lasts
hundreds of years and who knows how
technology will evolve whereas hydro
like why do we use it in certain it's
great in washington state it's not great
in nebraska so it just depends on the
topography you need large amounts of
downward flowing water so that limits
where you can actually have it so it's
an amazing thing
but it is limited by location also has
the disadvantage of
uh there are a lot of governmental
issues with it because it involves these
bodies of water it can involve
displacing a lot of people and there are
there's legitimate concerns about that
and what we hope is in the future you
know particularly when we have a nuclear
future you don't need to do that like
even if you have it you might you might
do it in regions where you really want
to have the dam to prevent flooding and
that kind of thing and it's where
actually it's making life better to have
the dam and it generates electricity but
maybe there are other regions where you
wouldn't want it except for electricity
and then you could have nuclear you
could have fossil fuels so uh it's it's
it's very revealing the most revealing
thing is that the the anti-fossil fuel
movement is very anti-hydro as well so
sierra club brags about how many dams
they shut down there's a lot of
hostility toward it in africa which is
particularly cruel because there are a
lot of hydro resources there and a lot
of poverty
and again i just keep arguing that
the the anti-fossil fuel movement is not
really interested in energy yeah yeah
just briefly touch on the global
politics of the anti-energy movement or
the anti-fossil fuel because there does
seem to be you know it's it not not
uh without reservation or exception but
it does seem to be coming mostly from
the wealthier you know the wealthier
north western europe north america
um and it it has a lot to say about
countries uh that are in a state of
development or a state of you know
absolute poverty either in the global
south or in places like china and india
um is that a critique that is that is
worth recognizing that you know what
this really is is about uh wealthy
people who will always be able to uh
heat not just their main residents but
their you know their jet planes and
their uh you know their vacation homes
all over the world at the expense of
poorer people well it's uh they're not
exactly heating the homes and fueling
the jets at the expense of poor people
what they're really doing is getting
approval at cocktail parties at the
expense of poor people which i would
argue is worse yeah but they're bad but
but it's worse i think it's i mean the
main thing that's worth pointing out is
just how important energy is and how
cruel it is to deprive anyone of it but
let alone people who have so little
opportunity and and you see this in the
investment world where it's easiest it's
always easiest to stop something new
versus uproot something old that's why i
say there's opposition like you can ban
fracking a lot more easily than you can
ban drilling as such it's why nuclear
has been so opposed because the
anti-impact environmental movement
emerged near the beginning of nuclear so
they couldn't get rid of fossil fuels
but they could stop this relatively new
thing and you see this very cruelly with
politics and with investment with the
developing world or the the what i call
the unempowered world where there's been
a focus on
like let's not
let's not have any new coal plants in
africa a lot of the announcements that
you get start off with let's not do
fossil fuel stuff in the poorest places
in the world and because they can get
away with that but it's so cruel what we
should be telling poor people is do
whatever you can whatever can lift you
out of poverty you do that because
you're like we could talk about a
climate crisis which is ridiculous
because we're safer from climate than
ever but
people in the world every day are
experiencing a life crisis by our
standards like if we woke up in most of
the world today we would consider it a
catastrophe almost everyone in the
wealthy world and so you always need to
keep in mind for example there are five
billion people making less than ten
dollars a day like the most of the world
is in a state that you regard as a
crisis and energy is needed to get them
out of that and it is so cruel
to oppose that and it's exciting to me
that we're starting to see um
more people say this i think it's
another argument that i've popularized
and i'm proud of that and actually we
might talk about the washington post
that's what they went after me on
non-coincidentally but i'm getting a lot
more allies in those places you know
particularly in a bunch of parts of
africa and uh from india getting new
people who are saying
this is totally wrong and and explicitly
using my arguments which is really cool
yeah let's talk uh let's do a little bit
of biography here you were born in 1980
and you grew up in the dc area in chevy
chase maryland which is one of the
wealthiest toniest suburbs in america
um what did your parents do and how did
your upbringing you know how did how did
coming out of that mel you affect you do
you think
so my parents my mom was a securities
lawyer and just recently retired so
she's kind of she at one on one point
worked at the sec it was kind of for a
long time i guess now so this is all of
a rebellion against your parents for
being instruments of the state
no no
i didn't think of it and my dad will
talk about instruments
so my dad has worked in the defense
department for almost my entire life
yeah but he works in something called
the office of net assessment which is a
pretty well regarded agency that kind of
projects the future of different
countries and that kind of thing
um the interesting thing about my
upbringing is my parents were very
they're very they're friends with a lot
of political people once i was around a
lot of political people but i hated
politics and to their credit my parents
didn't force any politics on me and so i
was very my whole background is math
science engineering like that's what i
went to one of the top schools in the
country for that kind of thing yeah you
went to duke as an undergrad right well
yeah yeah but before there's a school
called montgomery blair which is like a
top hundred kids in math and science in
montgomery county maryland which is a
big county and so that's where i got
exposed to really really smart kids
and but that was i'm just saying that
because that was my interest i wasn't at
all interested in the humanities but
then i i basically decided i'm tired of
hearing all these people talk about
politics there must be logical answers
and i just decided i'm going to figure
this out after totally spurning it all i
used to care about were was being an
athlete and then when i realized i
wasn't going to be a professional
athlete i wanted to be a billionaire
what was sure i liked practical things
what was your sport yes what what sports
could you like well
the problem was there was no sport i was
actually good at okay so i if you look
at my essays as a kid i want a
professional baseball player and i was
like a below average baseball player i i
do jujitsu now so i'm decent at that but
uh yeah no this this was clearly not
going to happen but the thing is i loved
i loved like physical practical things
and i did not like intellectual things
and it was so hard for me emotionally to
decide to become a writer and
intellectual but i just loved it so much
so it's the opposite of oh i dreamed of
becoming a writer and people are like
that was my nightmare yeah what i became
but now i like it because i just i love
ideas and i think they're very practical
and you went to duke uh what did you
study there
so i started off in um in computer
science and then midway through i i
finally came to terms the fact that i
loved ideas i loved philosophy so i
decided i'm gonna become a practical
philosopher and i told my computer
science advisor this is like this is
insane you should do software you
shouldn't do this i'm like i'm never
programming again
and uh
yeah i decided just to become a writer
and i spent my second half of college
just writing as much as i could and
learning to speak because it's terrified
of speaking in front of people basically
like training myself to become somebody
who could make money on the market
because i hated academia i did not want
to go to graduate school and philosophy
or anything else
uh so fortunately it all worked out
really well in the end but it was a very
unconventional plan when did you uh
encounter ayn rand uh you've mentioned
her a couple times today ein rand is a
big figure you're affiliated with a
couple of uh iran organizations or uh
related organizations uh who is in ran
to you
so i first heard about iron rand when i
was 16 and i kind of liked it uh but i
didn't look into it and then when i was
18 i met some people at duke who
i i by then even i was pretty good at
arguing and they were the only people
who could really beat me in arguments by
my at least by my own uh
beliefs and so i basically i mean then
it's pretty i i was trying to avoid
studying uh for physics one day and i
read letters of iron ram that was
actually the first thing of hers i read
and i read a letter to barry goldwater
and she made this point
that the united it's wrong to think of
yourself as a conservative because the
united states is revolutionary and it
was really like i don't know if she's
the word progressive probably not but
the idea was like this is a radically
different country so you shouldn't think
of believing in this country as
conservative and i just thought that's
an amazing argument and then i was so
fascinated just
she just wrote in a way and i just
thought i just thought this person has
different level than the people i like
and i like some good people i like
thomas soul i like the other people for
me she was at a different level i still
believe that so then i just read out the
shrugged and then that was i was in love
with that and uh
like a lot of other people i read
everything but i think maybe one
difference i had is
i always believed it was a huge
competitive advantage because i really
loved her mind and i thought she was
very underappreciated and so i
disproportionately studied objectivist
philosophy and i have no doubt in my
mind it's helped me do a lot of what
i've done in energy and i've recently
worked with objectivist philosophers
yeah do you consider yourself an
objectivist is that how you define
yourself i do but it's yeah i don't
think people know what that means so
what does it mean for you uh here's an
opportunity to kind of define it for
people well you need to talk about the
whole philosophy it's someone who's in
essential agreement with the philosophy
and lives by it but i think it's you
know so it's the moral purpose of your
life is your own happiness that's the
right purpose for everyone
uh you need to achieve that being guided
by your reasoning mind
and you know and that you believe in a
world of political freedom is necessary
to achieve that and so you know part of
it is believing that
you know one part of it i don't think
people get is the optimism of it
ein rand's view is that she couldn't
have come up with her ideas before the
industrial revolution because what the
industrial revolution really proved is
that human beings are productive
and that we can have amazing lives
individually in harmony with one another
and so she has a conception of
self-interest or selfishness but part of
what underlies that is that we can all
pursue our own happiness and it can work
really really well right and once you
view the world that way then the idea of
sacrificing for everyone else doesn't
make too much sense versus if you're in
a world of scarcity then you think yeah
we all got to sacrifice to each other
because if one person pursues their
interest then it's at the expense of
others if you view us as predators or
parasites but if you view us as
producers you have this amazing world
where like i can do what i want you can
do what you want we allow each other
freedom of action
and we live in this abundant world and i
still think the world has not at all
caught up to this we still have this
very scarcity mindset and um
oh now more than ever
yeah i love her stuff and uh yeah yeah
the uh scarcity
is radically i mean it's it's really
made a comeback even in just the past
few years i think you know we're we're
talking about scarcity all the time
whereas at least through a good chunk of
the 90s uh we were talking about
abundance really in a in a radically
different way
well also you notice this is related to
this idea of what i call the delicate
nurturer view of earth that the earth
unimpacted by us is stable
sufficient and safe so the sufficient is
interesting it's the idea nature gives
us enough resources but not not too much
so if we consume too much we're going to
run out that's one part of it but
there's also the safe the idea that it's
safe but if we disrupt it it's going to
become unsafe and you can see that's
really the dominant thread right now is
that we're going to anger the climate
and the climate is going to punish us
with all of this this danger versus
nature was already super dangerous we
need to develop mastery abilities and
the more mastery abilities we have
whatever nature throws at us or whatever
we throw out ourselves we can deal with
it really well and that it's kind of a
heroic it's a promethean enterprise in a
way not not that we're being wantonly
destructive but that whatever comes at
us
we will figure it out we will steal fire
and and create a world that uh where we
are as gods
and then part of it is is viewing the
earth as
a place we've made a lot better and
that's that's a big focus of mine and my
work and fossil future in particular
chapter four is called our unnaturally
livable fossil fueled world and it's
really trying to break this delicate
nurture view of the world and really say
so much of what you love about the world
including your ability to enjoy nature
is because
of um is because of these amazing
machines that are powered by this
amazing fuel and without that the world
is not a place you would like to live in
very much um
while you were at duke you uh you wrote
for a uh i guess
a jew usually called a conservative uh
student newspaper and there was an
article in the washington post that was
originally going to come out in one form
in the washington post that looked at a
bunch of those writings which
um and the way they characterized it was
that you know it was kind of a white
supremacist view or you know first world
view that uh the west is the best the
west is you know for kind of crypto
racist reasons superior to all other uh
cultures in the world particularly
in africa you uh mounted a preemptive
campaign against that article it was it
was tied to your book coming out and
about the the rising influence you have
so like in a way this is you know
exactly the type of article you want as
your book is coming out something that
is you know touting your influence even
if it's seeing it in a negative way
you mounted a campaign against that and
kind of i mean you you put out you know
a couple of hours worth of video
material where you kind of went through
you you kind of constructed the article
based on the fact checking and the
interactions that you had with people
and as a result you you the the article
that came out is still critical of you
but it really is a different story than
it would have been so i know a lot of
people in the media were very interested
in this and depending on you know where
they stand on a lot of different things
having to do with politics and ideology
but also legacy media versus new media
you know there are a lot of different
responses but um
what um you know
first the articles that were that were
kind of questioned had statements in it
like you know if you think um you know
if if you think all cultures are equal
um you know think about living in new
york versus chad
what were you going with in these kinds
of stories uh let's talk about that and
then we'll talk about the kind of
interaction with media which i thought
is very fascinating and interesting and
you know a real success on your part but
you know what were you getting at as a
undergraduate college student talking
about this kind of cultural difference
so as i've indicated i've you know been
an individualist for a long time
certainly since i was a teenager and so
the key element of that is believing in
freedom and and but you see believe in
individualism which is that individuals
matter the most and that they they
flourish and thrive in free societies
and part of believing in that is
believing that this is right in a
universal way that is it's certainly not
tied to a certain geographical reason uh
region and
it's certainly not tied to a skin color
right it's the idea about inherent in
human beings this is the right way to
live and to have societies and so i've
been i feel given that view i feel very
fortunate to be born in the united
states of america and more broadly in
what you can call western civilization
and it's been a big passion of mine to
talk about how more people should adopt
these views in different places around
the world uh you know regardless of skin
color but in different places around the
world tend to have different
concentrations of different skin colors
than we have here and so when i talk
about something like compare
leave aside i i communicate things
differently in college than i do now but
compare new york to being in chad the
idea is yes
chad needs more individualism and
freedom that is absolutely my view
because i think i want to be i would
want to live there and i think every
human being if they at least most would
want that and so i'm arguing this is a
superior idea and this is the key
superior idea and i made this very very
clear you could look at um the most
accessible things i wrote in college
were in the duke student newspaper
called
the chronicle and i had an article
called judging cultures is not racism
and i made 100 clear the difference
between culture which is about ideas
and racism which is about a superficial
meaningless characteristic namely skin
color i don't even like to call it race
because i think that's even misleading
so my views were totally known here so
and and those are my views that i do
believe that that these are universal
norms for every human being
and i would like to see them spread
around the world and absolutely i
believe some cultures are better than
others and i always use the example if
you don't believe that then you believe
that nazi germany under hitler is the
same as the united states today and i
don't think that's defensible view right
so um you know you you realized that the
washington post was essentially doing a
hit piece on you well they sent an
outline that called me a racist yeah so
which had quotes with me being called
racist so it wasn't a hard thing to
realize
um so um you know walk through the steps
of uh you know how you uh you you know
you took to
this alternative media platform twitter
basically i mean also youtube and things
like that to get your message out um how
did you put that together and are you
happy with the results so the first
thing was i didn't know what to do when
this happened i woke up on monday
morning having a really good plan for
the week and then you know you get a
note from your publicist saying hey the
washington post is doing this piece and
you look at it they send an outline and
it involves you being called a racist
repeatedly like that is not a and i know
a lot about persuasion the washington
post one of the most powerful media
institutions in the world running a
piece calling me a racist which is not
only false it is unbelievably that's the
most damaging thing essentially you can
do to somebody what is that going to
mean what are they going to say after
that well they're going to publish this
piece they'll circulate the hell out of
it they'll pressure my publisher to pull
the book even if the publisher doesn't
do that which i don't think they would
have but uh the the retailers can say
that right you get all sorts of people
messaging amazon don't do this racist
book et cetera et cetera et cetera um
and i knew that if i didn't comment
they'd just say we we reached out to
alex epstein he didn't have a comment so
that i'm a racist right
and if i did comment they would ignore
it or they'd mangle it and so i thought
the only thing i can do is i can do a
pre-emptive public comment where i tell
the whole story because if i tell the
whole story including every word that
they're going to try to use against me
that i wrote in college uh some you know
which i i think is none of which is
racist at all but some of it is not the
way i would say things now given that
i'm almost 42 versus when i was 18 and
19. i'm just going to give the whole
story so it's a hundred percent clear
that the story is not alex epstein
revealed as a racist because alex
epstein's an individualist the story is
the washington post is trying to cancel
alex epstein and fossil future based on
false racism accusations and to tell
that story took a little while so i made
this hour long it's been about eight
hours i went through every word of those
things i i and i put together this but
this is kind of a masterpiece yeah uh it
was like a weird use of my abilities to
put together this thing but it's an hour
long and it was really persuasive and i
think everyone who watched it thought
this is crazy what's happening and
fortunately i happen to know a lot of
influential people so i message them and
one person is my friend michael
schellenberger running now for governor
of california and he saw this and he
didn't see the whole thing but he just
saw a little bit of it and he happened
to be going on a little thing called the
joe rogan experience that day and so he
mentioned that and that helped a lot
and you know they're they're talking
about the story in so far as they knew
it at the time and a lot of other people
like scott adams if dilbert and
persuasion fame spread it and
so then they delayed the piece by a week
and then they took and that it was 90
sanitized you're still pretty bad i mean
some people's like some people said oh
this is great this is actually turned
into a puff piece i don't agree with
that at all but no there are no mentions
of racism and it wasn't anywhere near
the power and all of its cancellation
power
was destroyed so so the lesson i take is
if you're the victim of an unjust
cancellation it's very relevant that i
thought i was in the right 100
you should preemptively publicly comment
and the new media infrastructure of
social media enables you to do that in a
way that you did not have the option
certainly 20 years ago yeah no i i think
i i would hope uh you know i circulated
your work because i thought it was
interesting and i also thought it was
legitimate
um and but i would hope that anybody uh
regardless of the content of this would
look at that equation of what's going on
in the way that you responded and see
this is pretty great this is it's it's
pretty good when
an individual can talk back to a major
institution and really have an impact so
for me one thing is the institution one
notable thing is so and i would advise
this when you're doing it you should
always call for what you think is the
just action because if they're trying to
cancel me they're going to say hey pull
this book right so my actions were i
said and i didn't think they would do
them or i thought it's very optimistic
but i said you should fire this
journalist which i absolutely believe
you cannot do this to people because
again they're trying to dig up stuff
from 20 plus years ago like it's an
attempt to destroy me it's not an
attempt to understand me it's totally an
appropriate way to deal with one of the
world's leading energy authors coming
out with a new book you're the climate
reporter at the washington post this is
not an acceptable way to respond at all
uh and so i thought the person should be
fired the post as an institution owed me
an apology and that they should commit
to reforming so i think that's part of
the power of it they didn't do any of
those things right uh but
it's it's really important to have an
action and what they did do which was
notable and insane and and stupid was
they responded by accusing me of online
harassment
of the author yeah and and you you look
at my sub stack alex epstein.sec.com you
scroll down there are these letters
people wrote such eloquent thoughtful
letters to the washington post about
this people who knew me people like from
africa people like so many people said
this is unjust the washington post my
knowledge did not respond to one of them
all they did was they publicly smeared
all of us by i think the managing editor
saying
like you're harassing this person for a
story that isn't even out even though i
had an outline with quotes about me
being a racist
and
nobody found this plausible except the
climate journalism community this to me
was the most revealing is you had about
10 prominent climate journalists all say
maxine jaws allowed the post reporter
has been subject to baseless attacks i
made a one-hour video with all primary
sources they wouldn't even watch it and
they called it baseless attack so to me
this they did me a huge favor by proving
that the climate journalist
establishment is corrupt which i
painstakingly expose in my book but they
just proved it for me because they can't
even report on a simple cut and dried
story where a guy gives an hour of
evidence and you call it a baseless
accusation yeah
you run the center for industrial
progress a for-profit think tank what do
you do there
so
the main idea behind calling it that was
there needed to be a positive
alternative to the green movement so
before that i worked at the iran
institute um from 2004 to 2011. i got
really interested in energy in 2007 and
by 2011 i thought there really needs to
be a dedicated group that's offering a
positive alternative to this idea that
we should be eliminating our impact on
the world and so at the time i liked
industrial progress you know now i talk
more about global human flourishing
but it's essentially a company that's
and we're it maybe it should be called
the center for energy progress because
we're so focused on energy
but we're really trying to fight for
like energy clarity pro-human thinking
on energy and energy freedom around the
world you have a small staff and
they help with all my stuff and one of
our major projects called energy talking
points which people can see for free at
energytalkingpoints.com
and we actually work with um over 100
offices so in the last two years i've
gotten into politics and i work with
over 100 major offices helping them with
messaging and i think it's starting
you're starting to see some better
messaging from politicians and and i
think we'll see some better policies
uh particularly if congress turns over
um in the next couple of years
i do you think uh you know and and uh
met you you uh get paid by uh energy
companies or you speak at energy
companies and things like that um does
that
you know do you think that undercuts the
efficacy of your um of your message at
all
so i'm i'm glad you erased this now i i
get this question all the time and i
realized i've answered it but i should
just put it in writing so i wrote if you
go to
alex9.substance.com there's an article
that just has all of the details about
this but the
short version of this is i came up with
my views and started articulating them
when i didn't even know anyone in the
industry and i have been extremely
extremely poor having these um these
ideas and um but i've always believed
that the fossil fuel industry is good
and i wanted a way to work with them but
i wanted a way to work with them where i
had total independence and so my whole
career i've been architecting things
that way so the main way i did this is
historically i would never
i would just charge people for speeches
and for advice
uh but they would never fund any of my
public projects so that was one way i
did that a few years ago i decided to
change that because i was finding i was
doing too much behind the scenes
consulting which i didn't like and
didn't find effective so then i created
a vehicle and part this energy talking
points thing where people could
contribute but it was a large number of
relatively small contributions and and
they very explicitly had no editorial
control so every yeah so
i would
say if if you don't believe i'm sincere
and you read my stuff and see me speak i
i think most people do so it doesn't
actually come up that much it's more of
a talking point right for people who
can't refute me but if you want all the
details look at that article but yeah i
think i have
i i don't know of five people who have
more financial independence than i do
right in this in this world in the world
of ideas do you um do you think the
republican party
you know as as an institution is better
for energy policy um and are they are
they committed
to principles or are they it's just that
right now for a variety of reasons they
would be you know they're the party that
you find most uh amenable to your ideas
so i wish i could work with more parties
unfortunately democrats today for a
bunch of reasons are super hostile to
fossil fuels like one example that i
found disappointing was this build back
better
legislation that's happily collapsed but
you know the vast i mean i think only
one democrat in the house voted against
and i regard this as incredibly
anti-energy i was very disappointed by
some offices that i had talked to who
are democrats who still supported build
back better seemingly without qualms so
right now i mostly work with republicans
just um because they're much more
pro-energy and in terms of the principle
thing i think when you're dealing with
elected officials there's always this
tension between like what they think is
ideal and what they think will get them
elected and my goal is to always make
what's ideal more persuasive than what's
not ideal so i i only give
i'm very explicit with everyone i work
with i only share with you pro freedom
policies you can do whatever you want
but i will only share with you
pro-freedom policies same thing with
people who contribute again they have no
editorial control i'll tell them like
you can do whatever you want your own
business but like i am if you want
something that irrationally favors
natural gas in some context where i
don't think that's right that's too bad
i'm not going to do that and with
politicians so for example you have some
republicans talking now about different
carbon taxes such as an import carbon
tax what they call a border fee
and i'll say to them explicitly like do
not do this i will absolutely not help
you with this under any circumstances
and in fact i will fight you publicly on
this
and you know they're not paying me
they're just they're just there because
they find it useful and so i but i do
there are a lot of people who want to do
the right thing and don't think it's
practical and so i try to bridge that
gap for them right do you uh just
briefly uh on the issue of subsidies uh
lots of different energy forms get
different levels of subsidies could you
explain i you know i hear this a lot
that you know oil and gas are massively
subsidized and without those subsidies
there would be more of a level playing
field i know that obviously alternative
fuels or renewable fuels and whatnot get
massive subsidies something like the
nuclear power industry is like so
heavily regulated by the government
whether they're getting subsidies per se
or not it's you know it's hard to talk
about a free market are is oil and gas
massively subsidized directly or
indirectly and how does that stock up to
you know alternative fuels so in the
traditional and i would say proper
definition of subsidies um solar and
wind are vastly vastly subsidized and if
you want to see the data from energy
admin information administration at
energytalkingpoints.com just search
subsidies and all the numbers will be
there um so basically in terms of
actually giving companies money to do
something
that those subsidies are like 10x or
more for solar and wind this is just a
fact so when you hear about these claims
of subsidies um there are two categories
that don't really mean anything in the
in this argument of oh they would be
super competitive
one is poor countries subsidizing fuel
for their citizens so you know you can
say in the middle east let's say saudi
arabia the equivalent subsidizes fuel
for their citizens okay
we you talk about whether that's a good
idea or not but that is not the reason
why we're using oil in the u.s
versus other people it's basically
saying hey this we think this is really
valuable for whatever reason including
we want to stay in power and therefore
we're gonna we're giving this as welfare
but it's not that oh solar would be
super cheap it's that nothing is
affordable and that we're going to make
this the least the least cost thing
a little bit more affordable to people
because it's still unaffordable so
that's just that's just a welfare thing
the other thing that more relates to my
work is the argument that the quote
negative externalities of fossil fuels
are subsidies and i think this is a big
a bad mixture of categories but
essentially what they'll do is they'll
say well
i calculate that the cost of climate
change is five trillion dollars a year
fossil fuels are subsidized five
trillion dollars um i think one of the
best things about fossil fuels by the
way chapter four i think has in my view
the best discussion of this externality
issue that i've i've ever seen including
some new points but the basic points
here are one those calculations are
crazy because we're safer from climate
than ever uh two is all these arguments
ignore all the positive externalities of
fossil fuels uh which are huge because
what energy does among other things is
it frees up time so anytime you have
lower cost energy you have a lot more
time in the world that leads to
innovation and that leads to things like
the internet so if you're going to be
calculating externalities you need to
look at the positives and then the other
thing is these externality arguments
have this false view that the price of
something is somehow some perfect
measure of the value whereas often you
have
things at the same price on the market
where one is much more valuable than
another uh but because of the way
pricing works you pay a lower you pay
the same price for both so for example
like a gallon of oil or several gallons
of oil to save your life costs the same
on the market as a barbie doll but that
could be worth 500 000 to you if you
have it because it saves your life so
this is you can read the book for more
but these externality things are not at
all scientific most obviously because
they ignore the positive externalities
but also they have this false view of
of prices as perfect utilitarian
measures
um alex epstein final question are you
optimistic about the future and uh if so
why or why not
i'd say i'm unusually optimistic about
the persuadability of people um
about the truth that's a big motivation
of mine i'm very interested in
intellectual persuasion how do you take
somebody who expects to disagree with
what you think is true and how do you
move them from point a to point b it's
part of the reason why i spent three
years working on a new book is because i
have this confidence that i could
explain it better and every time i can
explain something better i get a better
result and i haven't even seen
diminishing returns in that in some some
ways it can be actually above a superior
it can be what's called a super linear
function which the greenhouse effect is
fortunately not
uh so
you know i think what we have is we've
got this anti-fossil fuel movement
that's making the world a lot worse but
we have more pro-fossil fuel people who
are thinking about it in a rational way
looking at benefits and side effects and
i'd say me schellenberger lomborg and
kunin uh matt ridley robert bryce now we
don't agree on a lot of stuff but i
think there's a general movement i think
that's getting traction i think the
other side doesn't have a response uh i
think you know immodestly i think i've
come up with a new level of making that
argument with fossil future and we
happen to be in a crisis that's pretty
clearly caused by the other side and i
think that is really leading to an
openness to new ideas so i think this is
a great time right now to get armed to
learn about these things and it can be
just like in the 70s the energy crisis
led to some better energy policies the
inflation crisis led to better financial
policies uh i think we can have the same
but it's not guaranteed you can have a
crisis that's misinterpreted and things
get worse but there is the opportunity
for things to get better so things are
going to probably get worse in a bunch
of ways for the next couple months and
that's tragic
we need to point out that tragedy we
need to at least make something good
come out of it by promoting uh the truth
so i'm very excited that this moment in
time i get the chance to make that case
to a lot of people when their minds are
open so i am optimistic we can do a lot
the other thing is
you know you live in an even when things
get bad in today's world you live in an
amazing world and you shouldn't
you shouldn't forget that because
whatever has happened in the past today
is the best time to be alive yeah all
right we're going to leave it there i've
been talking with alex epstein the
author most recently of fossil future
why global human flourishing requires
more oil coal and natural gas not less
alex thanks so much thank you